these actors skills have brought them
the success they deserve
but their confidence in themselves scars
and all
has made them into legends check out
these actors who have made the most of
their facial scars
joaquin phoenix is widely regarded as
one of the greatest living actors
he stands proudly for himself as well as
worthy causes like animal rights
his sense of self is so solid that he
can convey his internal world without
saying a single word directors have
often remarked enthusiastically
upon this dimensionality for the title
role in joker
the dedicated actor used the scar on his
lip
along with his distended shoulder to his
advantage
the scar is thought to be a microform
cleft
the mildest form of cleft lip however
due to the actor's relative silence on
the subject
the most we know for sure is that it
like his distended shoulder
has been with him since birth it has
served phoenix's career well
fitting perfectly into other roles in
which he's played tough
multi-dimensional characters consider
his turn in 1999's eight millimeter
where he investigates the snuff film
underworld alongside nicholas cage
or 2012's the master where we see him as
a volatile world war
ii veteran struggling to adjust to the
peacetime world
it's inspiring to see such primal
fortitude radiate from both the
personality
and physicality of this impressive actor
game of thrones casting of jason mamoa
as the formidable
khal drogo was a stroke of genius
imagining anyone else in the role is
impossible after the first season showed
the actor balance
fearsomeness with tenderness so
effectively
in 2011 the same year as game of thrones
first season debuted
mamoa also starred as the titular
character in conan the barbarian
both of these roles are for the manliest
of men
whose lives revolve around war dominance
and honor mamoa's scar fits these rolls
perfectly
just as it would eventually complement
his portrayal of the trident bearing
heir to the throne of atlantis in
aquaman
his eyebrow scar predates all of these
roles though
he actually got in a bar fight in which
he took a pint glass to the face
after the fact he felt somewhat relieved
at the idea that he wouldn't constantly
be called pretty boy anymore
that relief may have been premature
though because
fans of any of his roles before and
since the incident
still don't hesitate to swoon
michael k williams 25th birthday present
came in disguise
in a fight outside a bar from which
williams and his friends barely escaped
with their lives
one of the assailants cut the actor
across the face with a razor
he held it between his fingers here and
cut you yeah i thought he was smacking
me
things changed pretty quickly for
williams after this incident
instead of just dancing in music videos
directors started wanting him to play
more
thug roles eventually his new look
attracted the attention of others in the
entertainment industry
his breakthrough came when none other
than tupac shakur
saw one of his polaroids in 1996.
he thought that williams looked like he
deserved a part in his then
in production film bullet eventually
william's career took him all the way to
hbo's the wire in 2002
where he played trench coat wearing
stick up man omar little to massive
acclaim
an illustrious entertainment career is
an incredible thing to come out of a
terrifying near-death
experience sylvester stallone is
distinctive in just about every way
we recognize him for his dashing good
looks his voice
and his skill as a performer we know him
best from quotable classics like rocky
and rambo first blood
both of which were so popular that they
spawned series in their names
stallone's scars aren't extremely
noticeable but what is noticeable is
their effect
the result of a mishandled pair of
forceps during the actor's birth the
scars signify the severing of one of his
facial nerves
which left part of his chin lip and
tongue paralyzed
this partial paralysis has affected both
his facial expression
in his vocal patterns giving him his
iconic slight facial droop and low
pleasantly drawing tone while stallone
struggled initially to find success as
an actor
he wrote perhaps his most iconic role
rocky
himself and refused to sell the script
until he was granted the starring role
this is a man who knows how to use his
idiosyncrasies to his advantage
mickey rourke is a former boxer and this
has surely made a considerable impact on
his acting career
his commanding presence can't be denied
and we can only imagine what a fearsome
foe he must have been
in the ring he was no doubt much more
formidable than the washed-up
protagonist
randy the ram robinson who he plays in
2008's the wrestler
this role won the actor a golden globe
and a bafta award for best actor
a nomination from the oscars and several
other
independent critical awards rourke has
stated that boxing
in a plastic surgeon's botched attempt
to remedy his old boxing injuries
were the culprits behind his frequently
changing face
these changes have unfortunately been
the subject of tabloid speculation
while his incredible acting has
sometimes fallen by the wayside
the actor speaks with grace about his
transformations
both personal and physical he came from
a violent background
as a kid and the growth he's sustained
as he's explored his talents as
reflected in both his athletic
and entertainment careers tommy flanagan
is pretty much the dictionary entry for
tough guy
his most famous roles are universally
recognized rebels
he worked with joaquin phoenix on
gladiator in 2000
played morrison in the 1995 epic war
film braveheart
and of course played chibs telford in
the 2008 crime series
sons of anarchy the scars on flanigan's
face
the result of an assault outside a
nightclub where he had been djing
are incorporated into the character to
compelling effect
serving as the inspiration for the
nickname chibs
which is scottish slang for knife
flanagan
has had his scars throughout most of his
career and they've continuously enriched
his characters
and contributed to the formidable
reputation for which he is known today
harrison ford is one of the most well
recognized film stars of our time
he's best known for playing han solo in
star wars
and the titular hero in the indiana
jones franchise
for such charismatic distinguished and
adventurous roles
ford's chin scar fits perfectly it's
even been worked into the back stories
of the characters he plays
in 1989's the last crusade a young indie
defends himself against the lion by
picking
up a nearby whip and cracking it slicing
himself in the chin in the process
this scene gives us a window into indy's
improvisational nature
and his ability to take on new
challenges it also pays homage to ford
himself
by using one of his own distinctive
physical features
to provide a more intimate look at the
iconic character
the memorable scar has even been
incorporated into roles ford himself
doesn't play
alden ehrenreich sports a fake chinscar
for his performance as a young han solo
in solo the story of j.r martinez is as
harrowing as it is
inspiring the dancing with the stars
contestant and star of all my children
was deployed in iraq in 2003 when his
humvee hit a landmine
and trapped him in the vehicle 19 years
old at the time
he thought that these would certainly be
his last moments
miraculously martinez survived and went
on to give a very
informed performance as all my
children's brought monroe
a character who is himself a veteran
martinez's story has inspired not only
other veterans but burn victims
everywhere
since he's always worn his scars with
pride
martinez has visited other soldiers and
patients dealing with burns as well
providing emotional support and tangible
hope for their lives after recovery
he describes his experience as a gift of
inspiration
that he can now give to others as well
as one that shows him who truly loves
him for who he is as a person
luke perry's first major role as dylan
on beverly hills 90210
saw him portray a bad boy with a good
heart
the neat nick above his eyebrow serves
his rebellious aesthetic perfectly
in fact fans specifically obsess over
the scar on social media
as his career advanced perry's audience
only grew bigger
the actor was featured on a two-episode
run on criminal minds in 2008.
as a cult leader who'd spent time in
prison the final role of his career was
fred andrews on the 2017
tv drama riverdale as he tragically
passed away on march 4th
2019. fred is a gruff but wholesome man
who owns a construction business
and has hopes that his son might stick
around and follow in his footsteps
his hands-on lifestyle combined with
perry's scar
give off an air of capability and
solidity that serves as a lovely final
embodiment of his career
humphrey bogart was an iconic noir actor
and romantic lead
with 1942's casablanca serving as
probably the most well recognized
example of his
work part of what made him so alluring
was his tough guy
upper lip scar which also gave him his
trademark smirk
and his distinctive way of talking with
a slight lisp
and stoic stiff lip the scar was
distinctive enough to receive an entire
page of description
in a 1997 biography and that's saying
something
because bogart's life story is
impressive you don't get the american
film institute to describe you as the
greatest male
american screen legend of the 20th
century by being boring
bogart allegedly earned the scar during
his naval service
and had it sewn up when he began his
film career
from then on the scar helped him earn
the acclaim and renown he still
posthumously enjoys some faces are just
timeless
and dermot mulroney seems to be one of
them
from starring opposite julia roberts in
the 1997 romantic comedy my best
friend's wedding
to playing distinguished and gentlemanly
roles like russell on new girl
mulroney has always been an engaging
actor
it goes without saying that his scar has
always been an
integral part of his iconic good looks a
lot of people think it's a pyramid
scheme
but it's not on crisis an nbc action
thriller series that was unfortunately
canceled in 2014
mulroney played an ex-cia analyst who is
betrayed by the government
the stakes are high the character is
grave
and the scar works as perfectly as it
always has
accentuating his performance mulroney
has stated that since his scar has been
there since he was young
he doesn't think about it often some
facial scars are due to nothing more
than small accidents
others like adrian pasdar's scar are
remnants of near-death experiences
pazdar survived a horrific car accident
in college
which left him with scars on his lower
face sadly he was no longer able to play
football
for which he had earned a scholarship
instead he dropped out of college
entirely and took a job with a theater
group
the rest is pretty much history after
auditioning for top gun
director tony scott liked him so much
that he wrote the role of chipper
especially for him
it was a minor role but it was a major
foreshadowing of things to come
he has since enjoyed ongoing success
acting in popular tv shows such as
heroes
pasdar owes it all to the accident that
totally altered his life's direction
stacy keach often portrays policemen and
detectives on screen
his intimidating presence coupled with
his signature mustache
has made him a standby for these types
of parts what some people may not know
though
is that keach wears his mustache to hide
his cleft lip and partial cleft palate
as his career is advanced however keach
has started wearing his scars openly
honesty is an important message that
keach works to embody
not only for his own mental health but
also to proudly represent those born
with craniofacial differences
he joined the board of the world
craniofacial foundation in 2000
the year in which he also accepted a
position as a spokesperson for the
organization
while keach has played many parts in the
entertainment industry
from shakespeare performer to composer
the part of
advocate for the cleft community is an
incredibly special one
he stated in 2016 the message is
constant and clear
use whatever talent you discover you
have to offset any negativity coming
your way
let your special circumstances become a
motor to achieve greatness
in whatever field you choose to pursue
check out one of our newest videos right
here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you